47 % des
garçonnets pensent que les femmes
s'attendent les filles s'attendent à
être agressé sexuellement quand il ira
des relations sexuelles et 42 % pensent
que elles aiment ça nous ne sommes pas
des des senseurs ou des personnes qui
voulont mettre fin à la pornographie
nous voulons mettre fin à ce qui est
hors la loi ce qui est contraire au
droit ce qui est contraire simplement au
traitement humains des personnes donc la
fin des violences la fin de la torture
la fin de la barbarie tout cela que l'on
trouve donc abondamment dans la
pornographie et bien sûr de manière
illégale ça concerne 90
% des vidéos porno il y a disons presque
les violences ordinaires parce que c'est
normal que les femmes soient traitées
comme étant des des des des sous-êtres
humains qu'il sont qui sont juste
destinés être
piétinés et et a prisé et violé par les
hommes mais il y a quelques pratiques
mais maintenant qui sont légion et qui
sont carrément banales qui apparaissent
dans ces séquences que je vais vous
décrire et qui sont incroyablement
tolérés dans un souci d'urgence il faut
absolument que Faros la plateforme de
police administrative du ministère de
l'Intérieur élimine
les les les les séquence non seulement
de
viol de violence de torture de barbarie
enfin tout ce qui est absolument
contraire à notre code pénal en matière
de violence tout ce qu'on
peut dire aux enfants avant qu'il ne
voit la pour la première fois les images
avant qu'il soi choqué parce que
quelquesun quelquesuns d'entre eux sont
choqués à
vie sera utile il vaut mieux montrer
prévenir que guérir il vaut mieux
montrer avant en des DRAM
en disant c'est pas du tout comme ça
dans la vraie vie ça c'est comme du
cinéma malheureusement c'est pas du vrai
cinéma puisque les femmes souffrent
vraiment mais c'est horrible il ne faut
jamais faire ça je je suis pas une une
senseur dans là mais je suis quelqu'un
de très ouverte mais vraiment là ça
n'est plus possible on a atteint un
niveau de violence qui n'est simplement
plus tolérable pour la société